this time of year here in the Brooks
Range it's late winter early spring and
it starts getting warmer
pretty soon the meat that I have frozen
will have to be dried in order to
preserve it there's very limited space
in this cabin so I need to make a better
system for drying a larger quantity of
meat I can build a large rack right out
here in front of the window that way I
can keep an eye on it you can get a lot
of the things you need to live right
here you just have to use a little
imagination due to rising temperatures
Glen must process his winter meat supply
from his cache but first he will need to
build a new system that will allow the
meat to dry or risk losing it to
spoilage I'm gonna find four really
sturdy trees that I'm going to cut logs
from as I'm walking through the forest
I'm taking a good look at the trees
looking up at the tops I'm looking for
just the right tree the trees here are
alive they're healthy I wouldn't want to
cut those that's what I'm looking for
right there
there goes
I'm gonna cut down another tree
there it goes
we got four now four logs for four legs
of the meat rack plus I got a few other
poles that I'll incorporate into it just
gonna get these back to camp it's about
400 yards from where I'm going to build
this rack
I got a nice patch of ice uncovered here
I'm going to chisel some holes and I'm
gonna put the poles in that are gonna be
the legs on this meat drying rack
I'm chiseling a hole here the idea is to
secure this pole so that it makes one
leg for this meat drying rack I want to
be able to put four or five caribou up
on here I want nice and sturdy that
should be about deep enough beautiful
now I'm gonna grab some water out of my
water hole here jump it around that post
just freeze it into place that water's
gonna freeze this polish place it'll be
good and solid it won't move an inch
once it freezes up this rack will stand
right here until much later in the year
when Lake breaks up
two up two to go it's looking good
it's important that I can keep an eye on
this once I get the meat out here on the
rack there Wolverines around there
wolves around Bears are gonna be coming
out of hibernation Oh beautiful just
fill them with ice chips pour water in
it let it freeze got the four legs to my
meat rack right here in place leave them
overnight they'll freeze tight tomorrow
I'm gonna build the framework to hang
the meat off and to protect the meat